‏.
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد
كتاب الصلاه
الوسطى الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز حافظوا على
الصلوات والصلاه الوسطى
العصر صلاه العصر
صلاه العصر
صلاه
allصلاه
العصر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه العصر
عن انس رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم كان يصلي العصر والشمس
مرتفعه حيه فيذهب الذاهب الى العوالي
فياتي العوالي والشمس مرتفعه والحديث متفق
عليه
والعوالي
امكن في نواحي المدينه
انس رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلاه العصر
howes
would make
the horon and
صلاه
all theirts
of
and come back and the time of is what
this me
would make as
would as soon as the time would come in
so early a person coulday
‏some all the on the ed and come back
and
it is time for the sun is high in the
sky this narration is inl
having said that there is a great sin in
a person neglecting his prayer until the
time is over and this sin
‏magnified
person
time
this person
in
منته صلاه العصر عن ابن عمر رضي الله
عنهما ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول او قال الذي تفوته صلاه العصر صرف
كانما وتر اهله وماله وعن بريده ابن
الحصيب رضي الله عنه ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال من ترك صلاه العصر فقد حبط
عمله والحديث عند البخاري
ابن عمر
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه العصر
all
من فاتته صلاه العصر فكانما وتر اهله
وماله
صلاه
صلاه العصر
allدهن
الحصيبن
الحصيب
صلى الله عليه
صلاه العصر
de areified by
of becomes void because fail to make
this is
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه العصر نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد